the turkic language family is a huge
family of languages with over 170
million native speakers stretching all
the way from europe to northeast asia
there are many different languages in
this family including turkish
azerbaijani or azeri turkmen kazakh
tatar and wigar among others
interestingly i've spoken with people
from turkey who tell me that turkic is a
single language some of them said they
can understand every single turkic
language to a large degree but others
say that their comprehension is limited
until they get enough exposure to the
language the level of mutual
intelligibility is often highest for
certain languages that are
geographically close to each other like
turkish and azerbaijani which are said
to be anywhere from 65 to 90 mutually
intelligible azerbaijani speakers often
understand turkish better than the other
way around because they see lots of
turkish tv shows turkish speakers tend
to need several weeks of exposure in
order to comprehend what azerbaijani
speakers are saying quite well
this may also depend on the region and
dialect group north azerbaijani is
spoken in azerbaijan and south
azerbaijani is spoken in some parts of
iran
turkish and azerbaijani are both members
of the oz branch of turkic speakers of
oau's turkic began arriving in large
numbers in both present-day turkey and
present-day azerbaijan as well as
northwestern iran in the 11th century
when the seljuk empire conquered the
area then their speech began to diverge
into various regional and local dialects
especially since they usually lived
under different rulers the ottoman
empire had a standardized literary form
of turkish known as ottoman turkish
which was highly influenced by persian
and arabic and the literary language
used in azerbaijan was quite similar
after the ottoman empire fell turkey
removed much of the persian and arabic
vocabulary from literary turkish
creating a new standard form of turkish
that favored words of turkic origin
this never happened in azerbaijani so it
retains more of those words than turkish
does so whereas in turkey the word for
yes is evidence a turkic word in
azerbaijani yet
at least that's the word used in formal
speech the word for teacher in turkish
men and in azerbaijani
the word for school in turkish
and in azerbaijani
the word for province in
turkish and in azerbaijani
the same loanword used to be used in the
ottoman empire and in turkey until 1960
but it's not used for the modern
provinces the word for doctor in turkish
persian and arabic words like these in
azerbaijani often sound old-fashioned
and funny to turkish speakers but there
are still a decent number of arabic and
persian words in turkish too they
weren't all successfully removed from
the language it's also worth noting that
the turkish language reforms replaced
the perso arabic script with the latin
script which turkish is still written in
today
in iran south azerbaijani or azeri as
it's often called there is still written
in the person-arabic script
until its independence in 1991
azerbaijan spent most of the 19th and
20th centuries under the control of the
russian empire than the soviet union and
in 1939 north azerbaijani began to be
written in the cyrillic script it now
uses the latin script but there are
russian loanwords in the language for
example the word for closet in turkish
and in azerbaijani
the word for pencil in turkish
and in azerbaijani
interestingly this word was borrowed
from russian but russian actually
borrowed this word from a different
turkic language not azerbaijani but a
different one so it's like russian
borrowed the word and then lent it back
azerbaijani also has a cognate of the
turkish word
but it means pen rather than pencil
there were also words of russian origin
used in administration and military for
example the word for headquarters in
turkish madqueez and in azerbaijani
the word for division in turkish
and azerbaijani division
loan words aside plenty of other common
words are different as well for instance
the word for probably in turkish
and in azerbaijani dsn
the word meaning supposedly in turkish
and in azerbaijani
and the list goes on
as is normally the case with closely
related languages there are numerous
false friends in turkish and azerbaijani
words that look and sound similar but
have different meanings
yes yes in turkish this means summer and
in azerbaijani it means spring
in turkish this means muffin but in
azerbaijani it means bread
cool
in turkish this means postage stamp but
in azerbaijani it means money
sumik
in turkish this means snot as in nasal
mucus while in azerbaijani it means bone
in turkish this word means dirt in
azerbaijani it means harm or a harmful
act in some cases cognate words may be
difficult to recognize because of
multiple differences in spelling and
pronunciation for example the word
meaning like that in turkish
and in azerbaijani
the word meaning sublime in turkish
and in azerbaijani
the word for grazing in turkish
and in azerbaijani
there are many little differences in
pronunciation and orthography between
the two languages there are too many
little differences to talk about all of
them but let's look at a few examples
some of the words starting with the
letter b in turkish start with m in
azerbaijani while the other personal
pronouns are the same the one meaning i
is different in turkish ben and in
azerbaijani men
the word for thousands in turkish
and in azerbaijani mean
for some turkish words that have the
letter d or k in the middle the d or k
becomes doubled in azerbaijani look at
the following numbers for example
seven
yeti
also notice the k in turkish becomes q
in azerbaijani which represents the
sound ga as it appears next to the hard
vowels this is because the old
unpalatalized k sound became voiced to
ge in azerbaijani
still occurs but only in loanwords the
word for woman in turkish
and in azerbaijani garden
the word for far
note that at the end of a word q is
pronounced
the letter q is not used in turkish
for some turkish words that start with g
g is replaced with k in azerbaijani for
example the word for shirt
and the word for heart in the abstract
sense of the word
in azerbaijani there's a tendency for
side-by-side consonants to undergo
metathesis in other words their order
becomes reversed this happens in many
words in very casual speech but even
some standard formal words have
undergone metathesis the word for soil
the word for leaf
the word for naked
the word for incense
and in azerbaijani it means smoke rather
than incense
the voiced consonants
never occur at the end of a word in
turkish whereas they can in azerbaijani
in turkish their voiceless equivalents
are used instead for example the word
for book in turkish it's
and in azerbaijanitz
the word for crown in turkish
for turkish words that begin with vowels
it's common for the azerbaijani cognate
word to have an h before the initial
vowel pronounced ha for example the word
for spider
this word means knitting or braiding in
turkish
in azerbaijani it refers to braiding or
bricklaying like in
construction when the letter a comes
before v in turkish in azerbaijani it's
an o and the combination of o plus v
sounds like o
for example the word for rabbit in
turkish
and an azerbaijani
in turkish an apostrophe is used to add
a suffix to a proper noun like the name
of a person place or thing but not in
azerbaijani for example
this means in baku which is a city in
azerbaijan
in both turkish and azerbaijani there's
this letter in azerbaijani this letter
is pronounced
like a soft g in spanish in turkish it
isn't really pronounced as a consonant
anymore but normally indicates that the
previous vowel is lengthened in turkish
this letter called umushak ge or soft g
can appear next to any vowel in
azerbaijani when it occurs next to a
soft vowel it becomes y
for example the word for needle
the word for button
also when the letter g appears next to a
hard vowel in a turkish word in the
equivalent azerbaijani word it's the
soft g
called re in azerbaijani the word for
wave talga
the word for emotion do we
i should note that the more common word
for emotion in azerbaijani is
which looks to me like a russian
loanword
grammar the grammar of turkish and
azerbaijani is basically the same both
are agglutinative languages that follow
the same system of adding derivational
affixes to roots to create longer words
but there are some isolated differences
to use a verb in a subordinate clause
with the meaning of when the action
takes place the turkish verb has the
suffix
while azerbaijani has
for example the verb meaning to flow
with the following forms it expresses
the meaning of when it flows
in turkish
there's a difference in the definite
accusative forms of nouns in turkish and
azerbaijani when the accusative suffix
is added to a noun ending in a vowel in
turkish the consonant
is added to the beginning of the suffix
while in azerbaijani the consonant
is added for example this word which
means person in turkish and man as in
male in azerbaijani
now the accusative form in turkish
and azerbaijani
here's an example sentence in turkish
this means i don't know that person in
azerbaijani
this means i don't know that man
in azerbaijani the usual word for person
is
an arabic word that's also used in
persian
this means i don't know that person
why is there no sound in the accusative
form because this word ends in a
consonant not in a vowel
turkish also has a cognate of this word
which is a synonym of
but is used less often
in turkish there's a present continuous
suffix ior though the first vowel
changes depending on the vowels in the
verb root we just saw this suffix in the
previous sentence
this suffix is not used in azerbaijani
and might sound funny to azerbaijani
speakers for example this means he's
coming in turkish
and in azerbaijani
as is typical in agglutinative languages
this one word is a whole sentence this
is the root meaning come
this is the present continuous this is
the general present suffix and there's
nothing after that meaning there's no
personal ending so we know this is in
the third person singular he she or it
in azerbaijani there's a negative prefix
na that comes from persian which is
productive meaning that new words can be
produced using it in turkish it's only
used for a small number of pre-existing
archaic words for example in both
turkish and azerbaijani this word means
complete
in turkish the word for incomplete is
in azerbaijani it's
this means an incomplete sentence in
azerbaijani
aside from the different word for
incomplete notice that the turkish
phrase has an extra word in azerbaijani
there's no indefinite article but in
turkish the word meaning one can be used
as an indefinite article in a noun
phrase like this with an adjective the
word comes after the adjective if it's
being used as an indefinite article it
would come before the adjective if it
were being used as a number
unlike in turkish in azerbaijani the
question forming suffixes are placed at
the end of the sentence for example the
sentence meaning can you come over here
in turkish it's
nice
word for word it's here come able
question you are in azerbaijanitz
word for word it's here come able you
are question
but in daily spoken azerbaijani usually
the question suffixes are not even used
and questions are indicated with
intonation instead
also notice that in turkish
meaning to be able to is a suffix on the
verb but in azerbaijani it's a separate
word and other elements are suffixed to
it
as you can see turkish and azerbaijani
are closely related and very similar the
way they work is basically the same but
you also saw that there are lots of
minor differences in pronunciation
spelling and grammar that you would need
to become familiar with in order to
fully understand the other language the
biggest difference probably lies in the
vocabulary since the two languages have
moved in different directions especially
with the 1920s language reforms in
turkey
but they are indisputably sister
languages and a native speaker of either
one can get used to hearing the other
relatively easily speaking the other one
well is another matter and would
probably take longer the question of the
day for speakers of turkish and
azerbaijani how well are you able to
communicate with speakers of the other
language and to other people what's your
impression of turkish and azerbaijani do
the differences stand out to you as
major and now it's time to say thanks to
all of the langfocus patreon supporters
especially the ones whose names appear
right here on the screen because they
are the top tier patreon supporters so i
want to emphatically say thank you to
them
and to everyone thank you for watching
and have a nice day
[Music]
you